Hello! Welcome back to another episode of my cats reviewing things.
As a crazy cat mom, I gotta try out all these kinds of different products, see what my cats enjoy.
Then spread I the knowledge.
So today my cats are going to go in this stroller that I found on Amazon.
And we'll see if they like- uh- the outside world!
Let's start oldest,
'cause Lily's already here.
Oh, she's expressing her excitement.
And it's got like a mesh interior
which is cool...
And then you can just lock them in there!
Like a lil-like a little prisoner!
Are you excited Lily?
Let's go see the outside world, my love.
Oh, there's a lot of people coming by... so that'll- that'll freak her out.
It's okay! *Lily meows*
(Unintelligible words)
You're sitting the wrong way! You're supposed to enjoy the view of outside
Oh they sound so loud
Okay, ready? You ready?
Let's do this.
I see her little face from the mesh- Oh!
It's okay! It's supposed to be fun!
*Lily meows* You always want to go outside!
We'll go to the roof so there's less people
Oh look, I just bumped into the- *laughs*
I think she's really scared... I'm gonna take her back down
Maybe Congress could handle
But she's been out here a couple times now
*aggressively pushing close button* Byyyyyyyyyyye! We gotta go back down now!
You try to do good things for your cats
And- uh- it turns out they just like boxes and staying at home.
They're not very adventurous.
Here you go, you're free now!
I tried.
Next one!
Oh you look ready to go, Jimbo!
You look ready!
Oh you look rea-
*cat fighting back* You look ready to go!
Oh you look ready to go!
YOU LOOK READY TO GO BOY
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU WANT TO GO OUTSIDE!
Okay! Let's do Abigail!
Here you go, my love
Watch your lil head, watch your little tail
Watch the tail, k watch the little head
Got the mesh on ya
*Abigail meows*
*Abigail meows even more* Oh my goodness, already
Oh no
Nope! No, going back. Can't do it, can't do it
I feel like there's no point in taking fucking Jimmy outside
If they don't like it, Jimmy ain't gonna like it
I thought you would enjoy it, I'm sorry Abigail
I'm sorry. I thought you- you always want to look at the outside world
I got this for you and for Congo
...and for Jimmy
Well... at least try a new thing, right Jimbo?
We'll try a new thing, and if you don't like it, that's fine!
Well, if you don't like it, I'll take you back immediately.
*Struggling*
This is not a good sign... this is not a good sign at all.
Okay *sighs*!
Let's see if we can get 3 steps before he declares his hatred of it.
*Jimmy meows* ...Nope *laughs*
Okay! Buh-bye! Go ahead, bye bye!
Alright Congo. We'll see- ahh. You're the only one who liked the backpack
and the costume. We'll see if you like it
Here you go!
We'll see how far we get with you! Little boy! Huh?!
Hi!
How you like it?
He seems... chill
I feel like- when they have to go to the vet, this would be great transportation
Instead of having to carry a heavy box, you know?
And it's better than the backpack, I think
'cause at least they're not like jostling around with you
Plenty of space in there for you!
Oh he's just sitting!
Oh good boy! Good boy!
We're going to enjoy a nice stroll on the- on the roof.
He seems very chill, watch our for that uh- couch
Chill-ass time
Oh my god! You're so good!
You're the only one who's into new things
Let's see if we can even uh- pop this thing off so he can, like, enjoy the view!
Are you okay?
Kinda looks scared
Good job, baby! We'll go down to the apartment!
Nope! Nope! Nope, baby! Nope! Okay
Called it good too soon. I see how that is... you stay in there
Nope, we're on a roof- you don't die today
Look, you can see his little face over here
It's okay!
Duh, duh... congratulations!
So this seems like the perfect way to get them to the vet!
...except for maybe how to get this whole contraption in the car, perhaps?
But it's easier than I think a crate and lighter
And it seems nice cause I'll... I don't know, pushing around a cat in a stroller is kind of fun.
And if you HAVE to take them somewhere and they hate it, might as well take them to the vet in this thing!
I would highly recommend it for transporting your cat to-and-fro!
Especially if your vet is walking distance!
But- uh- otherwise, I have no use for it!
Cause- uh- they didn't like it at all!